ich hatte Frau bärburg gar nicht
geschadet ich glaube ich habe ihr
geholfen ich habe die Entscheidung
erleichtert möglichst schnell
zurückzutreten das Feld zu räumen es
kann ja nicht sein dass in Deutschland
allen Ernstes jemand für die
Kanzlerschaft kandidiert bei dem ich
mich fragen muss hat diese Person
überhaupt so etwas wie eigene Ideen kann
diese Person überhaupt selbst
formulieren wenn sie nicht ein Internet
ein internetlibretto vor sich liegen hat
von dem sie abschreibt bitte soll man
überhaupt mit ihnen eine wirklich
objektive Diskussion führen wenn aus
ihnen so offensichtlich eine vorgefasste
subjektive
schon zementierte Meinung über eine
Sachverhalt setzt wo sie als Gladiator
oder ja eigentlich
glaubwissenschaftliche arbeiten
untersucht was ich auf einen einzigen
Kandidaten jetzt fest weiß das ist
wirklich gelassen und genommen und das
können Sie gern machen aber ich möchte
gerne hier mit feststellen wir haben
wirklich wichtige Probleme als in einem
wahlkampfbuch festzustellen dass ein
paar Fußnoten zählen ich meine es fehlen
nicht einfach Fußnoten darum geht Frau
Wiener sie haben das Problem nicht
verstanden da müssen sie sich auf
Sendung besser vorbereiten tut mir leid
ablaufen lassen Sie uns kurz lassen und
deswegen wäre es schon wichtig wenn wir
mal wirklich inhaltlich über wichtige
Dinge reden also ich glaube wir haben in
den vergangenen Tagen sehr viel über
deine verrutschung der Werte gesprochen
und über eine Verlagerung der sachdhemen
mir wurde eine entsachlichung
vorgeworfen da muss ich sagen ich möchte
jetzt ernstlich dieses Thema in
Mittelpunkt rücken was hier passiert ist
und man kann er hier nicht davon reden
dass ein Buch geschrieben wurde das
wurde mittels copy Base zusammen
gestoppelt so dass man es eigentlich
jedem Schüler jedem 16-Jährigen
zurückschmeißen würde aber hier geht es
darum dass jemand copy pastet anstatt
dass es selber schreibt und ich sage es
nochmal das klingt so orthodox ja wie
von der Kanzel gepredigt wir haben in
unserer Kultur seit ca 1730 im Buchdruck
die Idee dass ein Buch auf dem anderen
Lena baerbock oben steht von der
annalena-behrburg stammt von mir aus
noch von diesem Herrn ebmayer
passagenweise wenn sie sich die meisten
politischen Bücher von Spitzenpolitikern
anschauen die sind das sind lauter
solche Co-Produktionen da kommt das
meiste was geschrieben wurde genau von
diesen Co-Autoren das ist aber
entstanden in Gesprächen mit den
jeweiligen Politikern und Politikern das
geht über alle Parteien hinweg also da
da würde ich jetzt auch um ehrlich aber
bitten
aber er schneidet
Party die Sie gerade hatten also was
kann
wissenschaftliche Arbeit mehr
Nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
Bild schau dir hier das nächste Video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren